(instruments warming up)
- [Instructor] Put your
knee track over your toe.
Good job.
(whirs)
(pulsing music)
(gulps)
(heavy breathing)
- John?
- Hey Erica.
- Oh my god, hi!
Oh I almost didn't recognize you though,
you look good.
- I lost a little weight.
- Okay, well it's working
for you, you look good.
- Thank you.
- You know you just missed
the reunion last week, right?
- How was it?
- It was cool, I'm not going
back for another like 15 years.
Everybody was either married
or engaged, or engaged
to be engaged, and I figure
by the time I go back
everybody will be on
their second marriages
and divorces, they'll lap me, you know,
that's when I make my move.
(laughs)
But oh shit, actually I'm running late
for therapy but I was so
good running into you.
- Yeah it was.
- We should hang out, we should totally.
- I'd love that.
- Yeah, you know Anne Dasilva?
- No.
- She's having a Halloween
party this Saturday
and there's gonna be a ton
of Polytech people there,
you should come.
- Oh I, I think I have
a friends thing but.
- Oh,
okay, alright.
- But it was like, it was
awesome bumping into you.
- Yeah, no, this was
great, you look great,
this was great, enjoy your friend thing.
- Yeah.
- Bye.
- Actually Erica,
- Yeah?
- I'd love to go to
your thing on Saturday.
- Okay, well then I'll hit you up.
- Okay.
(playful music)
(jazzy music)
(chatter)
- I'm sure Derek's happy
with this turn out.
- Yeah, he loves a party.
- Hi.
- Oh hi.
(laughs)
hi.
- Still don't know who you are though.
(laughs)
- Hi.
- Hi Anne.
- We went to high school together.
- Oh you came with the
little ninja costume alright,
that's very 90s.
Guess my costume.
- Kylo Ren?
- Pussy power.
- Yeah it's so easy.
- No one can tell.
- You know what stop salting my game.
Go find your man.
Okay, come on, let's go,
alright Anne we'll see ya.
- [John] See you.
- Oh Lord she actually
thinks we're best friends,
but I told my mom I want to be supportive
'cause she just got divorced
and you know how things go.
I mean are you're parents together?
- No, no.
- Okay yeah, I mean it's
just, I want to support her
but I don't wanna think of my mom fucking.
Am I oversharing?
- No no you're not.
You're good.
Do you know Lauren Boyle?
- Oh kind of.
- She's a friend from way back.
- Oh okay well you should
say hi to her then.
- Yeah I guess.
- Yeah, well I'm gonna go get a drink,
do you want anything?
- No I'm good, I don't drink actually.
- Okay responsible ninja, hey.
(laughs)
- Lauren Boyle.
John Kuwal, we went to Polytech together.
- Yeah.
Yeah, hey man.
- How you doing?
- Uh good, how are you doing?
- Great, great, do you
live in Los Angeles?
- Yes, do you?
- I do.
- Cool.
- Cool, cool, cool.
- I haven't seen you in like a decade.
- Yeah it's been a while.
- It's weird right?
- Yeah.
- Well it's great bumping into you.
- Yeah you too.
Good to see ya.
- Yeah.
(heavy breathing)
Hey Erica.
- Hey?
Why are you panting?
- This doesn't breath at all,
it's like (mumbles) material.
- I can imagine.
- Yeah.
- come on.
(rock music)
- You know what, no one
ever comes back here.
You're so strong.
I been waiting to take this off of you.
- Hi.
- Hey, Anne.
What the fuck are you doing in here?
- I just had to answer some emails.
- Okay, well we just came
in here to talk sure,
we'll talk outside.
- Whatever.
- Goodnight Anne.
- Come on John.
(kisses)
- It's a little, bright in here.
- No no it's fine, it's fine.
- I think we should the drapes.
I'm just gonna, I'm just gonna, hold on.
- Don't worry about it,
it's fine.
- Okay, okay sorry.
- Just sit down.
(moans)
- Actually can I just leave my shirt on?
- Is this okay, we don't have to do this.
- No it's totally fine.
- Are you sure.
(laughs)
(sexy music)
- Ah, um,
- It's fine, it's okay.
- Yeah I just,
I just need a minute.
- No, it's sure, take your time.
No, it's okay.
- Yeah, no, okay.
I'm sorry.
- No that's fine.
- I'm sorry just give me a minute.
(sighs)
(rock music)
(heavy breathing)
Fuck.
(claps)
Hey uh, have you seen a
girl in a cat costume?
No?
Okay.
(crunches)
(soft music)
Hi,
- Hey.
- You really don't remember me do you?
- I remember we went to
high school together.
- Chode.
- What?
- John Chode.
You used to call me Chode.
- Oh yeah, I guess we
had pretty stupid names
for friends in high school huh?
- We weren't friends.
- Okay.
It was high school, I don't,
I don't know what you want from me.
Like are you still hung up on this?
- You put pictures of me on the internet.
Fat bastard.
- We didn't make fun of
you because you were fat.
Charlie Cummings was fat
and he didn't have an issue with it.
He was like popular.
He had a girlfriend.
- Charlie Cummings was a drug dealer.
- Just wanted to get a rise out of you.
- How would you do that?
- I don't know because you
made it really easy dude,
you let everybody get under your skin.
You shouldn't take it so hard.
- I even missed a year of school
because you were so fucking awful to me.
- I'm pretty sure you
missed a year of school
because you pulled a fire alarm
during one of your melt downs.
That's not my fault.
Look I had a lisp in middle
school and people made fun
of me for that, guess what,
I don't have a lisp anymore.
And you look great, so maybe
all that teasing worked out.
- You're a bad person.
- Okay,
do you want my advice?
Put it behind you because you look great.
- Fuck you!
(soft music)
(siren wails)
(vomits)
(birds chirp)
(clicks)
(pulsing music)
(phone buzzes)
Hey what's up Erica?